こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
もうこの手の動画は何回撮ればいいん
だろうと思うんですけれども
未だに減らないですねいまだに減らないし
もう
毎年のことではあるんですけど
夏休みに入ってから特に増えます
お家周りの迷惑行為
もう何回言ってきたか
ごめんなさいね見てる人ももういいよとか
思ってると思うんですよもう何回言うんだ
よって思ってるんですけども言ってはいっ
ても止まんないから
止まんないし正直もう俺んち来るんだっ
たら晒す覚悟でいろって言うんであの
晒しますよ本当に動画撮ったり写真撮っ
たり家来る人って自分も動画撮ったり写真
撮られたり家来られても仕方ないですから
ねもうその覚悟を持ってじゃあ来て
くださいね
ということで今年の夏に入ってからもう何
件も僕の家に勝手に来たり
家の周りで動画を撮影したりもう今回は
もっと悪質なケースがありました全部お
見せできないんですけどもちょっと何件か
一緒に見ていこうと思います何でなん
だろうなやっぱ暇なのかな
夏休み暇だからかなただ今回すごかったの
がねもうね子供じゃなくて大人なのよね
マジできつい僕の家の周りで起きたことは
全部
録画されておりますので早速見ていき
ましょうあのこの動画の人
怒んないでね勝手にそういうことするって
いうことは勝手にこういうことされる覚悟
があるって俺思ってるからじゃあご覧
くださいどうぞ
はいまずはライトのやつから行きましょう
かこれねもう本当
昨日かおとといぐらいなんですよこれ後輩
の車でお昼ご飯買いに行こうっていう感じ
で一緒に車で移動してたんですけれども
この向かってる逆側から車が1台来ており
ましたちょっと今左にそれでかわそうとし
てるんですけどもはいこの車ですこの車
です家の前にずっと行ったのかわかんない
んですけど見ててくださいね
渡っていきますね
はいもう一度見てみましょうか
はい通りました渡ってる
当たってるねなんか窓開いてる
窓開いてるちょっと止めてみましょうか
全て見てみましょう
[音楽]
絶対に取ってやる
絶対に取ってる
カメラ回してる絶対
撮ってるよね絶対取ってる取ってる人の家
の前だよね取ってるよねカメラこっち回し
てるよねそれも監視カメラじゃわから
なかったけど俺の目の前で見てました家の
前でずっといました
ずーっとカメラで俺んち撮ってるよねそれ
も大人
おいおいおいおいおいおいおいおいおい
おいおいおいおいおい大人
撮ってるよねーそれ大人じゃないよねそれ
大人じゃないよねもう車の中見ました車に
人が2人乗ってました2人ともいい年した
大人もう30代から40代から50代
ぐらい僕より年上の男性と女性が2人乗っ
てました子供は確認できませんでしたが
多分いなかったと思います大人2人で人の
家の周り
車止めてまでずっと録画してました
ダメだよねおいおいおいおいおいまじか
お前らごめん年上かもしれませんがあえて
タメ口で話させてそれをやりすぎたな
落ち着き落ち着け年上には敬語だあのー
あのあのですねどこから話せばいいのかな
義務教育からですかね人の家の中を勝手に
取ると
嫌な気持ちになるんです人って知ってまし
たか子供関係なしマジの大人いい年した
それも多分女の人かな女性がねずっと
スマホこうやって向けてたのよ俺ん家で
こうやってでこの後輩の車に俺も乗ってた
んですけどももう取るのに集中してて
気づかないのよはじめしゃちょーがいる
ことに
もうこうやってガンガン動画撮ってて
ずっとえ
アホなのいやいいよ別に全然あのいいです
けど取るんだったら僕もこういう感じで
出しますよいやもうなんかその
何だろうマジでテンポ譲りますよ1000
歩譲ってうちの周りさやっぱりこれだけ
目立ってる家だし目に入るのは仕方ないの
よ
仕方ないですわかりますではじめしゃ
ちょーの家だってなるのも分かります
だってドアに映してるんだもんそういう
気持ちはわかるよとってもただよ
車から窓開けて止まってさオレンジの前で
動画通ってるのはちょっと
嬉しくないかな
嫌な気持ちになりました
悪いですけどももうこの動画撮ってたこの
大人の人たちのお家に僕行って動画
ゴリゴリに回してても絶対文句言わないで
くださいねそれで僕がこのインフル
エンサーとか家を映して何かやってるとか
そういうの関係なく普通に1人間として
守るべきルールだと思っています人の
絵を勝手に取らないとかこれがOKなわけ
がないじゃんこれOkにするとオレンジの
周りにひょっとしたらたくさん人が来てさ
もう近所の迷惑になったりするかもしれ
ないのでそもそもやっちゃいけないことだ
し僕の近所の人たちのためにも絶対やって
欲しくないですね
もう何だろう
天才だよ
逆に天才だよすごい
よくできるなこんなことがダメってわから
ないんですかね
わからないからこうやって動画に出してる
んですけどももう一度確認しますよ知ら
ない人が家に来るの
怖いです
僕怖いです知らない人家に来るのでカメラ
こうやって向けられて家を取られると
嫌な気持ちになりますこの2つだけですね
今日来ちゃったこの大人の大きなお友達は
この2つだけしっかり守って今日は帰って
もらえると
助かりますこれだけ気をつけようねあの
これされて多分いい思いする人って誰もい
ないと思うからさっきも言ったけど俺の家
は目立つし動画にも映してるもちろん目に
も入るし場所も知ってる人もいると思う
通りかかった時に目に入っておーとか言っ
ちゃったりこれが初めてになるのも
仕方ないけど
嫌がることはしちゃダメだ
嫌がることだけはやめてくれ
それだけどうか覚えて帰っていって
くださいはい
[音楽]
お願いします
では次の事件ですこちらこれねサーベと俺
が家にいた時の話なんですけれども
ちょっとバイクで移動とかしてて家の
玄関の前にバイク置いてありますはいもう
来ました
今車の影になってるんですけれども
はい子供だけかと思うじゃないですかご覧
ください
お母様も来ましたでも直でピンポン押しに
来ると
押してますね
お母さん
それ
飛べるよね
お母さんそこ親としての責務
責任
果たすよねなんで止めてないかなうん
お母さんそこを止めるよね
マジで
なんで止めないかなそれお母さんこの
男の子と他にもう一人
弟かなちっちゃい男の子いるんですけども
めちゃくちゃ
猛暑日なのにお母さんだけ帽子かぶって
この帽子かぶってないのよ
熱いよね絶対
絶対熱いよね熱中症本当に気をつけて
ほしいよね絶対気をつけて欲しいよね
お母さんちっちゃい子供
暑さに弱いのでしっかり日傘さすなり
帽子かぶせるなりしてあげてください
暑いと思います
[音楽]
話がそれましたはい子供がもうピンポンを
してオレンジで今
響きわたっていますピンポンが動画編集し
てる時にこれさ止めてあげてよお母さん
あなたしかいないんだよ止められるのは
それはダメだよっていうこと教えてあげる
のは
で出てあのインターホン見たら男の子の顔
がバーンて写っててやばいとやばいと思っ
たんですけどもちゃんと言ったんですよ
そのここ今
初めて社長のお家で仕事してるから
ピンポンされると迷惑だからダメだよって
言って
一応注意したんですよここででもずっと
落ちてるなこれ何回押してるの
お母さんお母さんダメだよ
マジであとその子供暑そうだからもう敷地
内入ることもダメだけどもう敷地内入っ
てるんだったらせめて日陰にさせてあげて
[音楽]
ダメダメマジでずっと待ってるのよもう
扉越しで僕注意したんですけどもそしたら
お母さんがねなんか手元見てこれちょっと
なんかんんこれちょっと止めますね1回
これ
絶対取ってる
絶対とってるよねこっち
[音楽]
向けてるよね
息子の夢
息子が会いたいって言ったから
叶えたよね
だめだよね
だめだよね起きてることじゃないよね僕の
家の敷地内だよね
いや子供が会いたいって言うんでじゃない
よねだめだよねそんなことしちゃ
だめだよ
[音楽]
ご覧ください俺が扉の前に来てこう注意し
だしたらお母さんスマホ向けだしたんです
よでも撮ってるけどなんか俺結構そのダメ
だよって注意したら
ゆっくりと後ろをずさんで行くんですよ
[音楽]
結構速い速度で後ろに下がっていきました
ね
そんな下がり方あるなんか俺が悪いみたい
になってるけど
[音楽]
怖がって下がってるみたいな感じになっ
てるけどで1回下がったんですけど
まだなんかここでモツモツはしてなんか
お母さんがね行ってきたみたいな感じ本当
は何が起きてるかわかんないけどなんか
行ってきないみたいな感じでこう息子を
送り出して俺の扉にパーン俺の扉にパーン
おいおい
いやこれはだめよ
ふざけてやっていいレベルを超えてますね
これは
これ僕ちっちゃい男の子がバーンてドアに
ぶつかってきたんですけど
あの子供とか大人とか関係なしに普通に
もう怖かったですマジで恐怖を感じました
これ俺嫌な予感がして建物じゃないなと
思って何かあったら普通にも警察沙汰だと
思って一応お家の中でも動画回してたん
ですよどうぞ
はい
ごめんなさいちょっとここお家なので
ピンポンやめてもらってもいいですか
ごめんね
ごめんねいいよいやよくないけど
こんにちは
怒ります
親もしっかりいます
親やばいな
いやー
ダメだよね
ダメよ
家にぶつかったらダメよ普通にマジ俺壊さ
れるかと思ったもんはい子供が買ってきて
ドカーンでぶつかって
多分ねこれお母さん遠くから笑いながら見
てるのよこれを
子供が走って戻ってって
このまま
ゆっくりと俺の家から帰っていくと
いやもう
終わってない世の中って思っちゃうね
世の中というかこれはね
ぇだろう
子供はさとっても
嬉しいことに初めて社長に会いたいと思っ
てきっと俺んち来てくれたのよ
その気持ちはすごい嬉しいし俺まで
ちっちゃい子供でさ近くに好きななんか
芸能人とかお笑い芸人とかいたらさ会い
たくなるなって思うんですけど
少なくとも俺の親は迷惑になるからダメっ
てやめなさいって注意してくれたと思うん
ですよてか注意してくれる親だったのよ
子供のそういうしたいこととかを叶え
させるのも親の大事な役割だと思うんです
けどもやっちゃいけないことをちゃんと
止めないと本当に別に子供がいるわけでも
ないから偉そうなこと入れないんですけど
もこれだけはわかるんですよ
そう育てられてきたから誰よりも注意し
ないと親が子供を
本当に子供ってね親の背中を見て育つん
ですよ本当にあすいません一応あの教育学
部出身なのでちょっとだけは話させて
ください本当に親の背中を見て育つので
マジで環境に左右されるのよどういう子供
に育つかって
頼むから
頼むからやっちゃいけないことはダメって
ちゃんと言ってあげてほしい何なんだろう
なやっぱいい顔したいのかな子供に
素敵なお父さんお母さん優しい
お父さんお母さんでありたいのかな
そんな綺麗事でやめ
な親じゃないですけどあんまり偉そうな
こと言えないんですけどやっちゃいけない
ことをやってる子供を止めないとダメよ
結果的にこういうようになっちゃってもう
お母さんの面接ぶっ潰しちゃってるから俺
今ぶっ潰すけどあなたが子供に注意しない
から俺が注意してるのよ子供の気持ちとは
やりたいことを叶えさせてあげたいという
気持ちは分かるけどそれで人に迷惑をかけ
ちゃいけませんよ
て子供はいないけども教育学部出身のあの
YouTuberが
喋ってます何で一人残らず動画回すかな
動画見せたら俺も回すからねなんか見る
限りお母さんもずっとニヤニヤしてなんか
初めて来てやったぞ感出してたなあ
ちょっとあのサングラスつけてたりしてた
んで年齢とかわからなかったんですけど
もう年齢とかこの際関係ないね怖いことさ
れた以上は俺もう
嫌なんで子供だろうと大人だろうとされた
事実は変わらないので
めっちゃ怖かったです普通に知らない人が
家にぶつかってくる気持ちわかります
思いました
男の子が会いに行きたいという気持ちも
伝わっただからといってはじめしゃちょー
の家に来てはいけませんお母さん
辞めさせてくださいお願いします
というのがね夏にありましたね全然まだ
たくさんありますよたくさんあるし全部
監視カメラに撮ってやりますからすいませ
んこういうことが続くようであれば持って
定期的に出させてくださいそして今一度
言わせてくださいこれだけ動画出しても
まだ家に来てそういうことするんだったら
それなりの覚悟を持って来てください防犯
上のため全て録画してありますそして
あなたが撮影したりカメラ回したりしてる
んだったら僕も同じようなことさせて
いただきますのでとるやつは取られる覚悟
があるやつそうやって僕は考えてます
そもそもそういう
嫌がるようなことはしないでください俺も
嫌ですし何よりも近所の人たちが
嫌な思いしたり俺が住んでるせいでなんか
騒がしくなったなとか怪しい動きする人が
増えたなとか
嫌な思いする人が増えちゃうのがすごく僕
は心が痛いので
本当にやめてくださいお願いしますやっぱ
夏休みだからかなでも今回夏休み関係ねえ
なだって大人だもん主犯が
今回お見せした2件は両方ね主犯が親なの
でちょっといま一度
自分がされてどうなんだろうっていうのを
始め社長がインフルエンサーとか有名人だ
からとかそういうの抜きでちょっと考えて
みてくださいここ家です最近やった僕の家
の周りでの迷惑行為を2つ紹介させて
いただきました次のこういう動画でお会い
したくないね
もうなくなることを願っておりますバイ
バイ
[音楽]